a seamless transition of power mint Oman
woke up to a new sultan while still in
mourning for their late monarch at the
royal palace haytham Ventana Khan Saeed
received world leaders there to offer
condolences and pay their respects to
omens new leader it's quite rare in the
Middle East for such a change in power
to be so smooth for the new leader to
inherit a country so stable and that is
a large part of the late Sultan cabooses
legacy at the Grand Mosque in omens
capital people shared memories often
speaking of Qaboos less as a ruler more
like family what they did for country he
brought from nothing like what you see
he used lost it's not a king pabu's
prioritize diplomacy over division
religious coexistence inside the country
political non-interference outside
neutrality as a way of keeping the peace
always very known in establishing peace
and we hope that his successor His
Majesty Sudan - aside to continue on the
same you know track and emphasize the
coexistence of cabooses reign was a time
of change spanning five decades but
there's been little pomp and
circumstance since his death the
transition to a new leader in a dynasty
that has ruled the country for fourteen
generations marked by the same quiet
dignity that caboose was known for
during his lifetime
Majid Abdullah Alice for worked for
Romans foreign ministry implementing
cabooses gentle approach to
international affairs he cared about
these people and he prioritized having
people's respect and he applied the same
principle when dealing with the rest of
the world
it's an approach ingrained in omens
institutions and unlikely to change
under new leadership Sultan Qaboos was
the quintessential elder statesman a
rare voice of reason who throughout his
public life held the middle ground in an
increasingly polarized Middle East and
Omani seemed confident their new Sultan
is the right choice to keep it that way
Zen Basra via al Jazeera Muscat